[Music]
so Natalie Portman at the Oscars gave it
okay wait
first let me show you okay some content
but don't you guys talk about Natalie
cuz I'm waiting that kind when I talk
about now okay fine thank you you're the
kind of white I have a lot of you dude
you look very white all right so here's
Natalie Portman at the Oscars and she's
wearing a cape that is so beautiful that
has female directors names like so like
what is this embroidered but I'm so glad
she's not [ __ ] gold oh thank god oh
god [ __ ] Hippogriff so what's going
on sarcasm because Rose McGowan she how
does she have such a big voice these
days no because she was assaulted but no
she was assaulted by Harvey Weinstein
like she okay Mandy was raped by him she
was leaving the meet no that's okay
that's not your bet
like you didn't know so yes so she was
raped by Harvey Weinstein and that's why
now a lot of people I mean when she says
something people are like y'all want to
hear you now cuz I didn't hear you
before yeah so that's how she started
I've been boys vocal about it yes Rose
McGowan is pointing out how Natalie
Portman Portman is a a what is it so she
was saying that because a lot of people
like the media they were saying that
Natalie Portman is so brave for her
protests her silent protest by having
female directors names in this cape and
so she was saying that what was the
point of having the directors name
because now you get nominated okay
process was it because they were way
Mara because they suck well the thing is
that it's really hard for females
objective is to get any sort of nominee
I remember Angelina Jolie was directing
something Julie as far as hiring when
you comes to hiring people the amount of
men to women is nuts right there have
only been five women women directors
ever to be nominated
ninety-two year history of the Austin
one of them would have had to be James
Cameron's wife first before she got
nominated like yo that's bullsh I mean
she got it afterward but that's annoying
okay now go off okay wait did he teach
her a lot of skills is that one come on
now come on now I'm not saying that I'm
saying who you know in Hollywood is so
[ __ ] important it has to do with
everything and by the way who you know
in life is about is like everyone in
this room probably because we know
people have benefited right right so
that's the point so Natalie Portman is a
master hypocrite because she uses
movements like me to movements like
let's represent people and she didn't
use me too but I'm saying that she uses
these movements to generate cliques for
herself she knows when she puts on this
outfit it's gonna generate a certain
honor Clint's for herself and get
herself a certain amount of light Wolf's
sure but that's not enough she has to
become relevant in the the spotlight and
so to do that she puts these female
directors on she's a [ __ ] they should
have [ __ ] given an Oscar to these
people but Natalie Portman's own
production company wouldn't hire a
female director in fact the only female
director in like the eight or nine
productions they've done or maybe
herself it's herself what if she's so
stupid that she's all like oh you know
what I'm a woman I should be hired as a
director more I'm gonna fight for more
women she's like yeah and then she
[ __ ] does it right and then when they
start hiring girls and honor on her
[ __ ] produc she's like nah they're
not that good I don't question the
sentiment she's talking [ __ ] to them I
question the do as I say not as I do
[ __ ] right where it's like hey just just
like dude why isn't Hollywood doing this
[ __ ] and then like when it comes to her
ability to do it she is Hollywood right
well let me actually this with with do
we know that the other projects that she
wasn't attached to as the director were
funded directly by her her company yes
because if they weren't like if the
money was coming from somewhere else
they also have the influence to say who
they want to direct it right so her
production company was involved in these
projects they never hired a woman except
for now Anna Coren
that's part of the thing it's like
you're working with Natalie Portman
right now form has a lot of pull now
important can make things happen
things not happening she could plug in a
female she didn't do it she didn't care
to do it it's so it seems Rose McGowan
ended up writing like a very lengthy
post on Facebook and I'll read part of
it so she says the kind of protest that
gets rave reviews from the mainstream
media for its bravery clicks [ __ ] no
not by a longshot more like an actress
acting the part of someone who cares as
many as so many of them do I'm not
writing this out of bitterness I'm
writing out of disgust I just want her
and other actresses to walk the walk and
then she ends up saying that Portman
only worked for two female directors
over the course of her entire career and
then like si said the fact that her
production company has only ever hired
one female director which is Natalie
Portman and as she said what is it with
your actresses up with actresses of your
ilk you a-listers could change the world
if you take a stand instead of being the
problem yes you Natalie you are the
problem
lip-service is the problem fake support
of other women is the problem I was at
the women in film event that you spoke
at once Natalie you reeled off
depressing statistics and then went all
black went all back to our salads but
then we all went back to our salads I
would I quickly realized you and other
women speakers and the joke of and
didn't have stage are just frauds you
say nothing and do nothing
so that's part of what she wrote but
then let Natalie ended up responding oh
[ __ ] yeah she's what the [ __ ]
did you receive you ready all right I'm
ready I'm ready to support her so
Natalie says I agree with miss McGowan
that it isn't it it is inaccurate to
call me brave for wearing a garment with
women's name names on it
brave is a term I'm more strongly
associated with actions like those of
the women who have been testifying
against Harvey Weinstein the last few
weeks under incredible pressure very
they've heard it create PR then she said
you're a firm wrote this [ __ ] she said
the past few years have seen a
blossoming of directing opportunities
for women due to the collective efforts
of many people who have been calling out
the system the gift has been these
incredible films I hope that we I hope
that what was intended as a simple nod
to them does not distract from the great
achievements it is true I've only made a
few films with women in my long career a
few films with women I've only gotten
the chance to work with female directors
a few times I've made shorts commercials
music videos and features within there
she lists women unfortunately the unmade
films I have tried to make are a ghost
history and as she goes on to say if
these films do get made women face
enormous challenges during the making of
them I have had the experience a few
times of helping get female directors
hired on projects which they were then
forced out of because of the conditions
they faced at work after they are made
films faced difficulty getting into
festivals getting distribution and
getting accolades because of the
gatekeepers at every level so I want to
say I have tried and I will keep trying
so while I have not yet been successful
I am hopeful that we are stepping into a
new day the paint the picture that she
paints that I'm confused about is I've
never heard this this stereotype or just
this thing of like guys going like it's
made by a woman I'm not gonna [ __ ]
watch this so that's what but that's
what that's half a new trend right so if
the movie bombs like the new Charlie's
Angels bombed and then Elizabeth Banks
goes I think it's because guys didn't
want to watch a movie that was directed
by a woman starring women and then
everyone's both like what about the old
Charlie's Angels everyone watched and
they liked it that woman no no but it
was starring women so everyone's going
like like why the [ __ ] did they did
movie guard them moviegoers don't
generally know who the [ __ ] directors
are they never know oh so they just
watched it because they're like I think
Cameron Diaz is probably hot I think
Lucy Liu is hot I think you know that
drew Barrymore is also very sexualized
no doubt but but that's what works right
so it like generationally wherever the
[ __ ] you are in the world usually sex
sells right that's the thing so and it's
worked for a lot of people on this
channel it's worked for it's worked for
a lot of people on YouTube it just works
so that's what's crazy is that Elizabeth
Banks claim some sexism thing even
though Charlie's Angels did well in the
2000 and I'm Soprano when I explained
the fact that she didn't hire any women
directors in a
because you have an argument she died
she can't argue because she kept excuses
like I try and then they gasp cancel
because the other men don't allow her
but you're the [ __ ] gatekeeper
it's your production company yeah and
there's no doubt by the way there's a
makeup [ __ ] there's no doubt in my mind
that sexism exists in Hollywood I know
what that [ __ ] is because it's always
like let's get a girl will cast her she
needs to look a certain way she needs to
be a certain dumbness or seem like that
so she's not too intimidating to men or
whatever the [ __ ] or whoever watching
this movie she can't look too
intelligent like that kind of [ __ ] goes
goes if it's baked into this man it's
hella later what do you write scripts a
lot of times like yo this chick is hot
as [ __ ] and just trying to describe
somebody who you think that the audience
will connect to but then you're like
wait I just wrote that she's hot as [ __ ]
why did I write that because it actually
helps your people visualize your script
and visualize a commercial success so
it's all baked into the cake of how we
all view [ __ ] in culture when I watch a
movie I am more inclined to like a
character if I find them attractive and
and and that's how men are wired and
women are more likely to like a
character if they find them attractive
like Ryan Gosling
so these in women we've been watching
him into exactly they either want to be
them or they look up to them exactly
it's just a bit yeah it's a very primal
[ __ ] trait that you can count on to
have your money make money so when
people do huge investments in something
they want that investment ROI and so
let's have our ROI payoff let's hire hot
people and so that's where the whole
thing gets [ __ ] again it's not that
it's not that it's fair it's just that
it's life and so that kind of becomes
the thing but with Kathryn Bigelow she's
a [ __ ] Academy award-winning she
wrote she did The Hurt Locker not deuce
Bigalow she did not do this big ya know
she was married to James Cameron so a
lot of people even in am sure even she
would say like yeah that gave me a leg
up and this [ __ ] and and but then a lot
of people say well women are wired
differently than men so it's less likely
that a woman would take on the [ __ ]
stress of a production because they're
less likely to try to do stressful jobs
compared to men as far as statistically
guys are more likely to be deep-sea
welders than women
duh like because it seems like a tough
game it seems like it can you could die
from it and you can't very dangerous so
there's a lot of things that are all
happening at once
you can't just blame one thing on and
say it's simple and I know on the on the
I've heard a common female side of the
argument is if you have the power to
shape culture you should use those
dollars to shape the culture because you
have that responsibility to do so
because of the way that it is right now
it's kind of like which came first the
movies or what people wanted so then
what people are used to in the movies is
our idea of what a hot sexualized woman
is right but then if we can desexualize
it through media and change how we view
women that's also a tactic that can be
done and it's the responsible thing to
do according to I think the female
perspective that I heard yes
so it really let go to blame a group is
what I'm saying no doubt but when you
have guys in media who can take their
shirts off and it could be on every
poster in LA and then a woman takes a
show off and it can't be on any posters
in LA you have sexualizes these women so
now when they're like their bodies are
not taboo so when you see their bodies
like oh I don't know like it's all kind
of part of the [ __ ] problem right
yeah it's not so you can't just go this
is the one solution this is the one
thing it's a big [ __ ] bit slow
thinking to go it's one group yes fault
for Amy they can't wait to [ __ ] in yeah
do this or that it's really just a bunch
of people trying to make money and like
what's the best way to do that and it's
not that it's good it's that that's how
other people make money on non
productions like a lighting guy makes
money because the director made money
because of rosemary money because the
movie made money like it's a lot of
things at once it's not so [ __ ]
simple but everyone makes it simple
because we're all we all can't read that
deep into things and we move on and we
don't live that world either to know the
multi-layer or whatever and it's easier
to just blame something it is good helps
you understand it's like well but it's
irresponsible and it's lazy thinking
yeah yeah and it's part of our stupid
[ __ ] sex shaming that we do as a
culture yeah definitely
[Music]